Hey youtubers it’s charlie and everyone
had a bunch of questions after sign of three
so I picked twenty from the comments on my
review video to answer.
A lot of you asked very similar questions
so I’ve just combined some of them.
I’m doing my breakdown on wednesday that
will cover all of the references to the books
and other shows like Doctor Who.
I’ve even seen a hobbit reference.
Also a lot of you asked questions about my
theories about the plot of episode 3 and the
main villain.
I’ll go into that more during the breakdown.
Be sure to subscribe to get it.
There are a couple shows that I normally do
that are coming back this week so we’re
almost back to our normal video schedule.
Since this video goes into specific details
for sherlock series 3 episode 2 careful for
spoilers if you haven’t seen it yet.
So lot of stuff to get through so let’s
get started.
Number 1 - Ian McGregor asks Please explain
how the murder knife worked.
So the Jonathan small, aka the wedding photographer
aka the mayfly man used a very thin knife
to stab both bainbridge, during the case of
the bloody guardsman and major sholto at the
wedding.
He did it through their belts, so the knife
had to be super thin and super sharp.
They didn’t feel it because the knife was
so sharp that it just felt like a prick.
He basically stabbed them and the idea was
that they would slowly bleed to death internally.
Question 2 - Jake Bamford Eldson asks why
do you think it was mycroft that was helping
sherlock in his mind palace instead of watson?
Sherlock manifested mycroft in his head because
either consciously or subconsciously he thought
that mycroft was the best person to help him
deduce the mayfly man.
Sherlock has already demonstrated that he
thinks mycroft is smarter than he is as seen
in empty hearse.
So his mind just summoned the smartest person
he knew.
Question 3 - Matthew Staton asks, was the
main villian of this series in the book?
If you’re talking about jonathan small lord
stabbington, then yes he’s based on a character
named small in the book the sign of four which
is what this episode is loosely inspired by.
The plot is entirely different but I’ll
talk more about that during my breakdown.
If you’re talking about Charles Augustus
Magnussen, then no, he wasn’t part of the
original story, he is mentioned briefly during
sherlock’s wedding speech though.
That will also be in my breakdown video.
Question 4 - Milena Torres asks do you think
the end of episode three will be a cliffhanger
for season 4?
Yes, when benedict cumberbatch and martin
freeman signed on for series 3 they also signed
on for series 4.
I’ll talk mostly about the plot of his last
vow when I do my videos for that episode next
week.
But yes, we are guaranteed a classic sherlock
style cliffhanger.
Question 5 - Lin Robinson asks, what do you
think the connection between Mary and the
main villain, charles augustus magnussen is?
I’ll talk about this in great detail during
my breakdown, but for now I’ll say that
when sherlock was reading the notes from people
at the wedding, one of the notes was from
the villain.
A nickname was used, not his full name.
So you can either re-watch that scene to try
and guess or just wait for my breakdown video
on wednesday.
But the fact that he sent her a wedding note
that was read aloud should give you an idea
of how close they are.
Question 6 - the sherlockedavatar asks how
do you think sherlock will handle being isolated
since the sign of three doesn’t include
him?
So you’re asking about what’s going to
happen to sherlock now that watson has a wife
and a baby?
Remember how sherlock carried watson around
in his head for those two years while he was
away.
When he was solving crimes with molly he kept
talking to mind palace watson.
The same thing will happen here.
Sherlock will still talk to the two of them
as if they’re always in the room with him.
And his vow was that he would protect them.
So he’ll have to be involved with their
lives.
So short answer, he’ll be lonely and use
the mind palace a lot, but watson and mary
aren’t going to desert him.
I think they consider him part of their family
even if sherlock doesn’t see it that way.
Question 7 - Fangirl1502 asks how will sherlock’s
last vow tie into the last episode?
The vow implied that he would die for the
three of them if need be and he’d stop at
nothing to protect them.
So I think he’ll end up in a situation that
he can’t solve.
He’ll have to make a choice that will mean
the death of one character over another.
Whether it’s his own death or mycrofts or
watsons or marys.
Martin Freeman signed a contract for series
4, so I think we can assume he won’t die
or benedict cumberbatch.
Question 8 - Mahmoud Lakhnavi asks what are
the true intentions of mary, is she good or
bad and what about news for series 4?
So mary is a good character, but remember
when sherlock deduced her it said disillusioned.
She has the wrong idea about a certain person
that will be critical to the plot of episode
3.
So no she’s not evil.
As for series 4, right now all we know is
that the actors have signed contracts.
I’ll be doing a predictions video after
episode 3 airs though.
Question 9 - FruityGaim asks is it the murder
game?
So you’re asking about the question I asked
you guys in my review video.
I said try to guess the new party game I was
going to try.
It was actually drunk deductions.
Eggy chair sitty thing.
Question 10 - Solaris290 asks were you surprised
to see donovan?
Yes, she wasn’t available for filming when
they were making episode 1, but the interesting
thing is that all of those scenes at the beginning
of the episode happened around the time sherlock
came back.
There was about 6 months between the events
of the last episode which took place in november
and this episode which is in may.
So donovan was around in november, but you
don’t see her at all during the current
time on the show.
So either she just wasn’t invited or something
happened to her in that 6 months.
Anderson isn’t around either.
Maybe the two of them started doin it again.
Question 11 - Flora3722 asks why is mycroft
wearing a wedding ring?
You have a good eye, when we see mycroft talking
to sherlock we see a ring on his right hand.
Most western cultures wear the wedding ring
on the left hand.
But it can also be worn on the right hand
as a sign of commitment or if it’s a family
heirloom.
Mark Gatiss has addressed the ring on his
twitter saying definitively that mycroft was
not married.
He said that it was a prop and it was intentional
on the part of the production team.
But he wouldn’t explain what it meant.
Anthea has a ring on her right hand too, so
let the theories fly.
I’ll talk more about it during my breakdown
video.
Question 12 - Kristine Silmaro asks why was
the episode called sign of three?
The plot was inspired by elements of the sign
of four book and A lot of the characters names
like Small and major sholto.
Sign of four involved this treasure plot that
mary morstan got tied up in, so a lot of things
were changed.
Question 13 - Marysol Losada asks is mary
standing in front of the horns foreshadowing?
it makes it look like they’re coming out
of her head.
This is both a funny reference to her being
a bit of a trickster.
She was playing both sherlock and watson to
get them out of the house so she could plan
the wedding.
But I actually do think it’s a general ominous
warning that there is a supernatural aspect
to her character, supernatural in the sense
that her character is much larger than what
the story has presented her as so far.
Good eye.
Plus that thumbs up moment was one of the
best jifs from the episode.
Question 14 - Wensley Talleyrand asks will
we see more of sherlock and the bridesmaid?
Only in hetero fan fiction.
Their final scene where she said I wish you
weren’t the way you are and he said me too.
Just means they’re both acknowledging that
they’re never going to be a thing.
Sherlock is too sherlock for his own good.
I’m sure if you search tumblr you can find
a little sherlock bridsemaid fic though.
Question 15 - siis saia asks what did red
beard mean when mycroft talked to sherlock
on the phone?
Mycroft was talking about the end of an era.
Redbeard and his brother were pirates together
and after his brother died redbeard continued
the tradition.
So mycroft was just telling sherlock that
he’d always be there for him and that after
the loss of watson (who is basically sherlock’s
other brother) sherlock would have to carry
on his work alone.
Question 16 - Devyn Straushbaugh asks do you
think we’ll see that one character from
the mind palace again this season?
No, not this series, but possibly another
cameo next series.
They don’t retread a lot of stories, so
I don’t expect her to get her own episode
again.
She’ll never be completely gone as long
as she’s rattling around naked in sherlock’s
head.
Question 17 - wh0urgrl asks will you do more
sherlock videos when it airs in the united
states?
Yes, they’ll be a little bit different,
but yes I’ll do something fun.
I might even do a giveaway.
Awesome channel by the way.
Keep making videos!
Question 18 - MariaVosa asks, what was up
with mary’s shirt?
You’re talking about the thumbs up shirt.
That was funny and weird.
I definitely got a vibe from her.
I think it was just meant to be funny and
just reinforce the idea that she thinks of
herself as a trickster.
She would have chosen to wear that shirt knowing
full well that she was giving them a thumbs
up while wearing it.
There are no coincidences on sherlock.
Everything has a purpose.
Question 19 - Yuki ame asks how do you think
mycroft would react if he thought sherlock
died?
And is sherlock becoming more social going
to hurt his abilities to solve crimes?
Good questions, I think mycroft would feel
an approximation of sadness.
Mark Gatiss’ version of the character is
much warmer than the book version.
He wouldn’t cry, but he would bring sherlock’s
killer to swift justice
And yes, I do think sherlock’s ability to
solve crimes will be affected now that he’s
so emotionally involved with watson, mary
and the baby.
I think that will play more into episode 3.
and question 20, last one - Ether says sherlock
is starting to explore the characters emotions
too much and less on the pure strain of his
core self.
The puzzle solver.
You actually had a pretty epic comment, high
fives.
This was a pretty common complaint I saw from
a lot of you guys.
I’ll say that yes, this series more so than
in previous series the character has swung
back and forth to both ends of the emotional
spectrum and has been profoundly weird.
In empty hearse he was completely disconnected
from watson in a human sense and now the three
or four of them depending on how you look
are turning into a family unit.
There was an anime episode i just did a video
for and the title was once more, with feeling.
Which reminded me of joss whedon’s buffy,
so I think the alternate title of this episode
is sherlock, once more with feeling.
What I think we’ll see in episode 3 is that
pendulum swing back to the middle.
He’s gone from super detached to super attached
and by the end of series 3 he’ll be back
to that middle ground puzzle solver you were
talking about.
So thank you so much everyone for submitting
your questions, I hope my answers covered
most of everything.
Like i said i’ll be doing a full breakdown
of the episode that will deal with a lot more
of the specific details and provide some contextual
clues for what’s going to happen during
episode 3.
Be sure to subscribe to get that video.
I’ll try to post it by wednesday.
Remember nothing on the show is a coincidence,
everything has a purpose, the clothes they
wear, the way their scenes are filmed and
the things they say.
Right now click here for my review of the
episode and click here for my breakdown of
episode 1.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow!
high fives!